hi I'm Christopher hin and today we're
going to be talking about kokun this
going to be a cun overview video KAG is
another one of these big ones so the
I've been kind of doing them the order
of hardest to understand or most
confusing or most involved um kokun is a
very pivotal throw to iido it could be
pivotal because a lot of schools call
whatever throw they do the most a CAG so
you can be in one school and they'll say
hey this this is a CAG and then that's
not the same throw in another school at
all uh I personally believe that's
because of what I think C you means and
when you hear me saying this right now
this is coming from me no one told me
this this is just how I interpret it it
makes it all make sense to me so
koku in English uh is often translated
as breath now breath throw sounds kind
of goofy lots of people will tell you
why they think cages are breath throw
I believe because cun nages generally
should exhibit the quality of coku that
um they're called CAG so any throw you
do really well you could call it KAG now
why it's called koku and meaning breath
that seems weird but it's because I
think we use or the Japanese are using
or osen say is using koku exactly like
we would use take a breath in English
right so you know if someone was freaked
out and going crazy and you would say
hey man stop take a break breath and
reenter yourself and and then you tell
me your story or whatever that's exactly
the way I think K is being used um in
iido which is to say that um you should
be in a calm and relaxed State when
you're doing uh the the throw or when
you're exhibiting C you so I always tell
my kids that coku means calm ready right
so I'm calm and I'm ready just like I
would be if I took a big breath right so
cages are throws that should be done
from the Cal and ready State now when
we're talking about a technical form of
coku for kokun nag then it has to look a
certain way because if it doesn't look
that way it's super confusing to new
people so if you explain to new people
that cages are throws that are done from
a calm ready position that's really not
helpful to a brand new person so I use a
specific form it matches up with the
major iwama CAG and I say that with a
smile because um in in iwama KAG could
be a whole bunch of different things but
the main KAG is the one that I call KAG
and I limit our school to just that and
it's a side by-side throw I'll get Josh
over here and we'll go over it for you
[Music]
[Applause]
Josh all right let's talk about KAG so
the throw that I call KAG is a side
by-side throw like this where I come in
through like this and I throw the guy
right and I think a lot of schools call
that KAG um there are major exceptions
like damic sphere has that listed as an
ed nag and not a KAG the naming
convention is probably because you make
an EDI on it right so if Josh I here
side by side to get into there I have to
Ed me in to get into Josh and so that
makes perfect sense I I think you could
call these things all every anything you
wanted you could call them A B and C
throw if you wanted right um so the name
doesn't really matter as far as the
technical form goes except the fact that
we all call it the same thing so when
I'm referring to a CAG that's what I
mean by it all right now what makes a
CAG come off a CAG comes off because and
let's go actually let's go sideways to
the camera here because I step behind
his lower body and put my arm across the
front of his body and I split him in two
and when Josh is split in two like this
it's really really hard for him to stay
standing now different teachers will
emphasize different ways to do this and
sometimes there's lots of arguments
between Styles because um this way must
be right or that way must be right I'm
going to give you an overview of a few
of them and you can decide for yourself
which ones you want to do I think in
truth they're all situational sometimes
uh one works out better than another in
different situations the basic one that
I used to work on that I like the most
was sinking lower than him here right so
I really emphasize getting your hips
lower than his hips and cutting them as
far forward as you can and then when
that's done just Naturally by turning
here we get a CAG okay and so that's the
one that when I was working on my cagot
and I very first started teaching that
was the one I did the most because I
thought it was the coolest it required
the least amount of force and and got
the job done really nicely I thought it
was really great there are lots of
reasons why that one might not work one
is if you got a guy with really low Bas
right so so let's just imagine I'm way
taller than Josh I am not so let's
imagine and so this is as low as I can
get right I can't do that throw that's
an impossible way to do this throw now
there are other versions that could be
done where I emphasize a Timmy up top
and you see I drove his upper body over
and I don't get much on his lower body
because I can't get under it in that way
so I just kind of stick my foot back
there and I go through with my upper
body and I can get him to bend with my
upper body coming in that could be done
with the elbow or with the hand if you
do it with the hand a lot of times that
can lead into juji nag but that's
another video um so so that's another
way to do it and a lot of times you'll
see this in teachers where they're
really emphasizing this part I
originally thought that was bad because
it was like oh it's terrible to hit or
something I don't know what I thought
but but it's just another way to get
them to bend backwards and the way you
should think about these throws is how
do I cut his legs One Direction and his
upper body the other direction and
that's what makes the caga happen so
however that can happen you could do it
as simply as having a foot back here and
a hand coming up here because that gets
the same split in the body which is a
really natural way to make him fall down
if his feet stay in front and his uh
upper body goes behind then that will
get a cun nagate to come off um the main
things that you want to try and
emphasize are that hip connection right
cuz this will do it better right so if I
can bump that hip a lot of times I see
people having trouble with their CAG
it's because they're not going through
his hips so when I push my hips into his
hips his hips have to go somewhere and
so unless he's really rigidly locked his
hips are going to start moving away and
if I time that with his upper body
turning he's probably going to fall but
remember in iido even if he doesn't fall
who cares as long as he stumbles away
from me I made the distance which is
what nag waza is for all right now as I
said if I was pushing in into his hips
come over here for me okay so as I'm
pushing into his hips let's say he
braces himself against this right so I
go to move his hips and oh they got
solid if I sink under those suddenly
this guy will start to break down and so
that makes a really easy KAG here for me
right so that's the basic idea is I Go
hip to hip with this guy and then I try
and move his hips with my hips while
turning my upper body to get him to to
fall over if he's too stabilized I try
to shoot underneath his hips and that's
going to Buck his hips forward a little
more it's going to make an easy C nuget
if he is too low for me to do that then
I really emphasize the upper body
hitting him in the face and that breaks
him back more and as I said that could
be done even from here right I could do
it from here and I don't even have hip
to hiip contact now that's a weaker form
of CAG but it can be done and why I said
in the beginning that they're
situational is because it depends on the
guy I'm facing if this guy's really
short he's going to be hard to throw
with that Sinker if he's really tall
it's going to be easy to use that Sinker
but it's going to be hard to hit him in
the face because he's so tall I can't
get my elbow up there right so imagine
Josh is this much taller than me and I'm
trying to Elbow him it doesn't work
right but my my lowers my uh center of
gravity is so much lower that I can
easily take him out here so you're just
adapting those methods to the person
you're dealing with in order to make it
work best now one more thing I want to
talk about in this video is why would
cagis happen because you don't see cun a
ton in sport martial arts they happen
every now and then I've seen some
highlight videos where people say hey
look here's a KAG and that's cool you
know like two MMA guys and a CAG comes
off it happens but it's going to happen
more in armed conflict than it happens
in unarmed conflict and the reason is
because if we have a weapon right so
let's say Josh has a weapon here okay
and we're struggling over this I can't
be hanging out here in front of Josh
because he's going to be hitting me and
switching so I'll immediately want to
pull this weapon away as far as I
possibly can okay now of course this
gives me Roos and all kinds of things up
here but if those aren't working out for
me I might need to use a CAG and so in
here nudging his hips will work really
nicely for me so I'm always going to be
turning to this side bys side position
um and the same is true for him if I had
a weapon and he wants to get away from
this he's going to turn to that side-by
side position and again here we have a
setup for a cun so cages are going to
happen all the time it is one of the
higher percentage techniques you'll see
in um our kaishi waza and our randori
right because um they just it happens a
lot because of where you'll want to
position yourself when you don't have
the weapon right so that's the reason
cagis are so essential to uh iido is
because they'll come up all the time
you'll be using them a ton and then
those basic pointers I gave you are the
ways to to start to look at it and kind
of break down for yourself what cun nag
is so this is Joshua thi I'm Christopher
Hine and right over there is Maya salano
McDaniel there she is she's right right
she's there look over there yes good job
all right okay uh we will see you guys
in the next video thanks for watching
[Music]